R
EYES TAKE OCCUPIED NOW ENHANCED
WITH VITAMIN D. DO YOU WANT UP
AND THEN TURNED AROUND AND GOT
OUT TO TELL ME SOMETHING? AND
THAT'S WHEN IT STARTED COMING AT
ME LIKE WHOLE FOREST. THAT'S
WHEN HE TRIED TO JUMP BACK IN
THERE. HE SLIPPED BECAUSE THESE
TRACKS THERE'S NO WAY THAT
THERE'S NO WAY TO STAND. JUST
TRY TO JUMP ON IT. JUMP ON IT IN
THE TEAM UNDER AND IT TOOK HIM
UNDER. THAT IS HARD TO HEAR.
WE'RE SEEING NEWLY RELEASED BODY
CAMERA FOOTAGE TAKEN MOMENTS
AFTER FIRST RESPONDERS RUSHED TO
HELP ACTOR JEREMY RENNER AFTER A
NEARLY DEADLY SNOWPLOW ACCIDENT.
CNN'S CHLOE MELAS IS JOINING US
NOW. CHLOE THE AVENGERS ACTOR
SAYS HE BROKE MORE THAN 30 BONES
AND SUFFERED SEVERE INJURIES.
THIS HAPPENED ON NEW YEAR'S DAY
, RIGHT? YES AND I MEAN,
SPEAKING OF THOSE INJURIES, WE
KNOW BECAUSE HE JUST RECENTLY
SAT DOWN WITH DIANE SAWYER THAT
HE INCLUDED EIGHT RIBS BROKEN IN
14 PLACES. AT ONE POINT, HE SAID
HE SAW HIS EYE OUT IN FRONT OF
HIM. IT HAD COME OUT OF ITS
SOCKET. SO MANY INJURIES, BUT
THE GOOD NEWS IS HE WAS ON A RED
CARPET RECENTLY AT THE
RENOVATIONS, PREMIER WALKING
WITH A CANE, BUT HE IS WELL ON
HIS WAY TO RECOVERY. BUT THIS
BODYCAM FOOTAGE. IT TAKES YOU
THERE. WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ACCIDENT SINCE IT
HAPPENED ON NEW YEAR'S DAY,
THERE WAS A HUGE SNOWSTORM,
THOUSANDS WITHOUT POWER IN THE
AREA, AND JEREMY WAS OUT THERE
WITH THAT MASSIVE SNOW CAT
£14,000. WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT CAN YOU IMAGINE HE'S OUT
THERE PULLING A CAR OUT OF THE
SNOW WITH HIS NEPHEW. HE GETS
BACK IN THE CAB AND OF THIS
MASSIVE SNOW CAT, AND HE USES
THESE ALL THE TIME ON HIS
PROPERTY BECAUSE HE'S LIKE A
MOUNTAIN GUY RIGHT OUT OF HIS
HOUSE IN THE LAKE UPPER TYPE
EXACTLY LIKE HIS SHOW, AND SO HE
GETS OUT OF THERE, AND HE'S HE'S
OVER THERE AND HE JUMPS OUT OF
THE CAB, AND HE'S TRYING TO TALK
TO HIS NEPHEW. AND THAT'S WHEN
IT STARTS TO ROLL TOWARDS HIS
NEPHEW. AND THAT'S WHEN HE SLIPS
ON THOSE TRACKS AND GETS CRUSHED
RIGHT UNDERNEATH. IT IS A
MIRACLE. HE SURVIVED THE BODY
CAM FOOTAGE. YOU SEE ALL HIS
NEIGHBORS AND PEOPLE AROUND HIM
AND YOU SEE AT ONE POINT, SARAH,
WE THOUGHT THAT PERHAPS THERE
WAS IT WAS LIKE A SNOW
EMBANKMENT. NO, IT'S ASPHALT
RIGHT? HE IS COMPLETELY CRUSHED
. COMPRESSED UNDER THAT, BECAUSE
IF IT HADN'T BEEN SNOW, AT LEAST
HE WOULD PUSH DOWN INTO THE SNOW
OF IT. YOU HEAR THE OFFICERS
ASKING? YOU KNOW WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED? DO YOU HEAR THE NEPHEW
EXPLAINING HE'S TRYING TO WAS
TRYING TO SAVE MY LIFE. YOU SEE
THE BLOOD EVERYWHERE AND
REMEMBER BECAUSE THE ROADS WERE
BLOCKED OFF. I MEAN, THE STARS
ALIGNED THAT DAY FOR JEREMY
RENNER. DESPITE HOW AWFUL THIS
WAS SARAH. THE ROADS WERE
BLOCKED OFF. IT TOOK HELICOPTERS
AND AUTHORITIES A LONG TIME TO
GET TO HIM, AND THEY GOT THERE
JUST IN TIME, TERRIFYING
ACCIDENT, BUT WE ARE GLAD TO SEE